si no allora cercavo se non si può
mettere ciao ragazzi come avevo promesso
è arrivato il famoso video the idea
prima di partire proibite volevo
salutare 3 di voi e alla fine del video
troverete le istruzioni per farli
salutare nel prossimo video allora oggi
saluterò evelyn palese 16 chiara varisco
e gaia loves nutella siccome intanto io
e te chiesto marina visto che ci hai
detto che hai ancora i tuoi vecchi diari
leggi insieme a noi e è arrivato poi è
arrivato finalmente il momento di aprire
c'erano i diari di prima seconda terza
media ma soprattutto il capolavoro della
prima liceo
partiamo dalle medie allora di angela
prima media un diario sobrio stranamente
innanzitutto i siti da non perdere
canale 5 mi spears molto bene questi
soli siti da non perdere passiamo alla
parte filosofica con queste due frasi
che sono tratte da un libro di poesie
del novecento ed è la vita è come la
scala del pollaio breve ma piena di
merda oppure la vita è come un albero di
natale tutti ti rompono le palle e delle
tecniche anche marina marina marina cosa
potrei dirti se non che sei una ragazza
un po di un po birichina ma non importa
una bella dedica sicuramente era
un'amica e riuscirai nostre ore a farla
franca sarà franca farsi nostri eroi dei
compagni di classe molto simpatici
passiamo al allora c'era delle pagine
dedicate a san valentino quindi il
titolo della pagina era pensieri
stupendi dove ogni ragazzino ovviamente
riversava il proprio romanticismo la
propria voglia di un amore forte nelle
parole che trovava più adatte queste
sono quelle che ho riversato io su
questo foglio 6 lui che mi sta vicino
fosse bello io gli direi fammi il regalo
di san valentino o ti tira un pugno
si passa bene l'amore la vostra parola
sulla parola cuore peccato che l'accento
si posa sulla parola muore c'era
dell'ottimismo e ma continuiamo subito
quando venezia non avrà più il mare ti
potrò dimenticare questo è un po più
soft
se cupido da un cuore cadrà io lo
aiuterò ferendoli lei in cambio cose mi
dà l'amore dell'uomo più bello del mondo
e io risposi ho capito e flavio del
grande fratello per me chiaramente era
lui l'amore arriva della parola amo
peccato che non ha pochi con i
pesciolini che sono lì con l'amo sopra
di loro molto artistica allora
ovviamente non lo sapete ve lo dico io
ero la regina delle feste dialoghi tutti
tutti gli altri
la festa di halloween della classe si
svolgeva a casa mia quindi nella sezione
dedicata ad halloween feci un comunicato
stampa per appunto non c'era questa mia
festa mercoledì 31 ottobre alle 9 di
sera e comincerà la mia festa di
halloween
gli invitati sono pulite jennifer elisa
e naturalmente io quindi è un 3 più mero
4 imitati dopo resteranno a dormire poco
batto confessioni di ogni genere zucche
fantasmi scheletri vorrà evitare qualcun
altro ma tutti vanno a fare le vacanze
perché c'è il ponte ok sono indecisa
sotto invitare alla fine ero rimasto in
quanto è stata una bella festa e si
appella questa questa penso non delle
dediche per i ragazzi se i ragazzi
brutti fossero fiori stupendi la mia
classe sarebbe uno dei giardini più
belli del mondo i ragazzi sono come i
bagni sempre occupati 66 brutti ragazzi
fossero granelli di sabbia la mia scuola
sarebbe un deserto
se un ragazzo ti molla di vita d america
capirà che siete stati uniti
così si usa essa è un gioco di parole
ragazze un altro livello ad agosto
come sapete le pagine le vacanze estive
vengono riempite di dediche cose varie
scrivevo vedo il sole e vedo che vedo la
luna e vedute vedo il mare e vedo te per
favore spostati
ecco bellissima messo l'elica non voglio
oro non voglio argento voglio te al
cento per cento e che carina
il trojan fischia il vento tace
scordarmi di te non sono capace quindi
c'era già ero già diventata più dolce in
questi ultimi giorni di scuola
se vedi la ciabatta ricordati di
un'amica matta chiaramente ciabatta
amica matta che come stato dei problemi
di me raga
la scuola è come la luce della vita vuoi
un consiglio resta al buio
qui il testo di shakira whenever
wherever chi adoravamo soprattutto il
video lei che ci saliva fuori dall'acqua
tutto quel momento di bacino ancorché
belly dance di musica di quella quella
l'esordio della bella idea shakira e
seconda media
secondo media sempre comunque il muto
rosa si chi da non perdere
vv cui saranno famosi punto it possono
andare a saranno famosi i miei miti
discoteche se io scrivevo le discoteche
dove andare a mia sorella finge il dopo
sono risposte che dove andava a ballare
io ho capito facciamo secondo lei
ovviamente non andava discoteca comunque
c'erano tutti i locali devi essere
andata sabato sera io per farmi la
figlia rischio non sia mai che qualcuno
pensasse io comunque serie tv del cuore
beautiful centovetrine streghe e sabrina
e cuore rubati che non mi ricordo che
cos'è adesso una cosa tristissima
ma andiamo avanti il roma tematica ma
soprattutto un bel rapporto matematica
sufficiente è molto incerta nei calcoli
e nel collegare le informazioni presenti
saranno della cretina tutte le
insegnanti di matematica ho avuto la mia
vita mi odiavano le vecchie al liceo e
ancora remi fare quindi la matematica lo
sempre non ho capito se io di avola
matematico pure il fatto che loro
mediasse melodia non arrivati comunque
bellina matematica non abbiamo mai detto
gara poco ma andiamo avanti perché ci
sono altre note di questa signora di
pieno di col nome ma lei sa che è vero
alberto sembra una nostra amica prof
l'insegnante di matematica sei sempre tu
lo sai non ha svolto tutti gli esercizi
allora era il caldo estivo una nota che
tutti ogni tanto non facciamo gli
esercizi non mi sembra giusto questa ce
l'aveva con me ragazzi ce l'aveva con me
educazione artistica allora io ho sempre
mi sono sempre chiesta i voti no delle
medie ultime questi quasi buono più che
buono addirittura qui benino
che cosa vuol dire benino cioè veramente
dove si reinventano alimentavano si voti
bene benino più che buono ottimo meno
nella stessa pagina della
la media ho scritto ho fatto una
bellissima festa di halloween con tanto
di addobbi abbiamo guardato scary movie
2 e ci siamo divertiti
io mi sono vestita da strega e mi sono
messa dei tacchi altissimi
che bello a lui passiamo alla terza
media la terza media una versione un po
minimal odierno della terza media è
molto minima c'è una banconota da 500
euro
sicuramente vera un tuffo dentro e una
cartolina di david beckham trasformato
in una dolce signorina ma soprattutto è
caduto un free drink
forse questo è il segno che in terza
media sono anche la mia prima festa
sicuramente sarà stata pomeridiana è
comunque un drink in caso ci troviamo un
bigliettino rapa gestito britney primis
che saranno idro e scrivevo picnic
ovunque poi ho scritto pomp l'inconscio
freezer
che cosa ci sarà dentro un segreto io
ero innamorata di tom welling infatti
come potete notare era anche nel nel
retro del diario sempre lui io
innamorata di a scale del grande
fratello oltre a tom welling penso al in
terza media aveva attaccato la foto come
potete vedere gli avevo scritto ascanio
lascia perdere katia sono meglio io
chiaramente allora lui detto una casa
grande fratello si è fidanzato con katia
che adesso dopo dieci anni ancora su
dieci avuto figli di famiglie
meglio comunque ero meglio doveva
scegliere me quando è stato eliminato
dalla casa di grande fratello io sono
andata a scuola e piangevo perché ero
disperata da questa notizia
io non vedo l'ora di andare in provenza
solo che sei ore di viaggio da un po
lunghe che palle a me vengono in gita
che culo tu non ne avrai già più questi
erano discorso importanti spero tanto di
stare in stanza con te sono
contentissimo noi non abbiamo inglese e
proprio carino il costume del saggio il
bianco però è il colore più carino ma
rinuncia c'è un problema ho paura che mi
voglio oggi puoi venire da me tanto per
domani noi abbiamo compiti mari scappo
che ti voglio bene ma non ho più voglia
di scrivere ha studiato per circa due
ore altre materie durante educazione
artistica ragazzino si fa durante il
compito ha usato la calcolatrice
nascosta le portate in ed era sempre lei
era sempre lei la prof
non vi sembra strano è sempre le note me
si distrae durante le lezioni c'è
addirittura un che ho avuto con l'auto
ragazzi ma se questa sera fissata deve
essere più sicuro e geometria un'altra
nota che non sai deve esserci volante
ma passiamo al 16 luglio dalla taglia
compleanno che happy birthday to mi 14
14 anni l'età giusta per un nuovo
cellulare il motorino mai visto e molto
altro molto bene dopo aver dopo aver
visto con voi diari delle medie passiamo
al dialogo strobel ci regalerà più
emozioni tutti addetti diario della
prima liceo voi soprattutto vi
chiederete perché maria via attaccato
delle gradito odiare non lo so è un
diario che ho paura di aprire un diario
che spesso pieno di roba e sembra tutto
tranne che un diario scolastico
non so come mi abbiano permesso a scuola
deve così allora apriamo il diario ci
sono subito delle citazioni tra metri
sopra il cielo
ci sono due giorni a cui non penso mai e
ieri e domani da tre metri sopra il
cielo
questa è una citazione importantissima
che gli usi che comunque ha segnato
tutte noi negli anni 90 ragazze del 2000
sono avete visto guardate tre metri
sopra il cielo perché ha fatto la storia
poi andando avanti troviamo questa foto
cosa sono e come non esistono commenti
si commenta da sola
e lo lascerei così interpretabile
ah che bello questa è la foto di giraffa
dove l'ho fatta una foto di leoni anche
qui sarà andato a 10 sopra i cieli o le
giraffe coccodrilli ci ha condotto a qua
inizio i bigliettini ragazzi l'amore
quali sono le dichiarazioni importanti
già caro marina io vorrei chiederti una
cosa molto importante per me voglio
chiederti se vuoi farti una storia con
me quando ti guardo mi fa impazzire
638 [ __ ] mandami una rissa nel secondo
intervallo ai 9 sono scioccata ma c'è un
altro bigliettino
cara marina ho saputo che adesso sei
rimasta single o tipo se rimasta vero
sei rimasta single
vorrei sapere se tu vorresti metterti
come rispondi tra virgolette per favore
quindi anche in ogni agenzia educata ma
c'era una nota sempre la stessa ragazza
che a quanto pare era fissato ma mi
potrò dimenticare il giorno in cui ti ho
vista dal primo momento mi sei piaciuta
non riesco a pensare a nient'altro che a
te mi piace il tuo modo di fare e non mi
importa di quello che pensano gli altri
di me perché io ti amo e non smetterò
mai di pensarlo
ormai mi hai fatto innamorare it e per
me tu sei la persona più importante del
mondo quindi sono giunto alla
conclusione marina tu mi piaci troppo
perciò ti metteresti con me so che sei
fidanzata però non mi stancherò mai
richiede
qui c'è un primo selphy allora avete
presente
belen quando arrivare foto facendo finta
di non guardare obiettivo cioè no se le
fa solo bene ci facciamo un po tutto
però diciamo che fa abbastanza ridere il
mood di fare le foto facendo finta che
non ti stai facendo una foto anche se
non c'era di cellulare c'era né
macchinette digitali
io l'avevo fatta
avevo posato la macchinetta su uno
scaffale e ho fatto finta come sir in
camera a guardare il vuoto e qualcomm e
fotografarsi ecco perché sabato io e lo
cc many judy abbiamo visto sto di film
però faceva ho paura
carina nella recensione top comunque mai
un pista era direttamente poi messaggio
per gli insostenibili adulti cento
meglio il messaggio per insostenibili
adulti adulti poveri adulti non
ragionate più la vostra mente pensa solo
al denaro al lavoro allo shopping allo
sport non a veterani maggio due giochi
al di noi ragazzi che non ci vergogniamo
72 giorni siamo vestiti uguali o se la
scuola prendiamo brutti voti invece poi
cadere dalle nuvole se vi licenziano e
poi soprattutto le donne sempre lì a
truccarsi cambiarsi andare dal
parrucchiere ragazze sono io questa e
fare le oche non è che non sono credo
che i parrucchieri dovrebbero essere
aboliti presto 9 raiti sta decollando
non sopporto le donne con mille mesh e
le parrucche
ci sono donne che vivono di telenovele
ma questo non le contesto perché lo
faccio anch'io un messaggio bari adulti
non pensate solo a voi guardatevi
intorno alla natura gli animali e gli
ante persone che circondano
unitevi e formato una popolazione adulta
che vive in pace e segue le orme
cristiane non si capiva quale la mia
mentalità perché in verità se tutti
possiamo veramente cristiani nel mondo
non ci sarebbero guerre e catastrofi un
consiglio rifletteteci su che non
abbiate paura di abbassarvi a seguire i
consigli dei giovani bene dopo di ciò
sono diventata presidente degli stati
uniti ma passerei alla scheda tecnica
del mio primo fidanzatino avevo questa
fissa ogni volta mi piaceva qualcuno di
fare una scheda tecnica proprio nome e
cognome capelli colore occhi proprio
parla fisico e la nostra canzone primo
bacio e ultimo bacio ai durato per 2 3
mi sono rotta ovviamente le palle era
una cosa un po ridicola però apparire
la prima scheda tecnica ovviamente i
dati persone lo ridico capelli castani
occhi castani bellezza il voto della
bellezza 6 simpatie apporto più e
charlie puzzava un po di friends on
durata storia
nove giorni una storiona e anche le date
primo bacio e ultimo bacio ma
soprattutto una cosa su cui riflettere
molto è fisico muscoloso tra parentesi
relativamente allora non si sa perché è
meglio che si sia messo questo pezzo è
stata una storia comunque importante
durata nove giorni e la bellezza da sei
quindi facciamoci durante praticamente
non esiste ma ora però la parola prince
8 giada percepivo nell'area vi ho già
capito tutto ancora nascere quella
parola è così giunti al termine del
video spero tanto che mi sia piaciuto mi
raccomando se volete essere salutati nel
prossimo video dovete semplicemente
seguirmi su instagram inviarmi un bel
dare con scritto il vostro nome e mi
puoi salutare sul prossimo video e
aspettare ovviamente il prossimo video
su youtube per vedere se siete stati tra
i tre fortunati ad essere salutati sei
video vi è piaciuto come al solito
lasciate un commento e mettetevi un bel
like e ovviamente se non siete ancora
iscritti iscrivetevi al canale
ricordatevi anche di seguirmi sugli
altri social instagram facebook e music
e ad ora
[Musica]